voicemail we have a voicemail number the
number is two one nine to david p let's
take a listen to this voicemail but hi
david this is lorenzo calling from
skokie illinois and i just had one quick
point when you start off with hatred
mail you you know that the voice they're
often says well typically usually could
always says because america and because
patriotism away never I think you might
want to change that a little bit instead
of saying because America you might want
to sound more like because America it
looks quite more typical of how these
types talks yeah it's like the titles
you get india and the emails that you
get from these people so that's all i
want to say thanks great show by the way
well it's a fair point which is the
introduction to hey treat male says
because america because freedom but
really your average hatred maybe would
say because merica not because america
so maybe it's something that we could do
to further improve hey tree mail I don't
even think we have to re-record it I
think we can just snip off the a we
could do that in editing in POTUS yeah
alright well we'll look into it at two
one nine to david p you can call any
time of day send us your thoughts leave
us your messages on the bonus show today
there was basically no bonus show
yesterday production blew up yesterday
because we had just a lot of extra stuff
to produce yesterday and in order to get
we had to decide between being thorough
or being on time and in order to get the
show out on time to everybody we had to
do a 45 second bonus show even though i
was very upset that was furious
absolutely he flipped over the foosball
table out in the common area because he
was so angry today we're going to do a
great bonus show and we're going to
reveal a new what would you call it a
feature of the david pakman show yeah
that's a nice way i leave it without a
stylistic feature of the david pakman
show we're going to reveal on today's
bonus show we will also talk about a
russian officials seeking to ban Beauty
and the Beast over a gay character we're
still doing this and also there's this
quiet upstate New York Road which since
the election of Donald Trump has become
a very busy exit from the unit
states also yelp has started tracking
gender-neutral bathrooms for transgender
individuals and obviously there were
people who are angry about that we're
going to talk about that in detail how
do you get access to the bonus show very
easy become a member go to david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code I voted 17 is still available you
get a hundred percent of the benefits
for forty percent off how can you go
wrong with that